il ya peut-être sur le plus long terme
un risque inflationniste mais
aujourd'hui il faut quand même dire la
réalité c'est juste une constatation par
rapport à une crise qui a eu lieu
l'année dernière une crise historique
qui a fait s'effondrer les prix
le niveau général des prix donc
attention pas de panique on n'est pas en
train de 2,2 craindre une inflation
aujourd'hui à tout va même si en fait il
ya il peut y avoir des risques
on le voit bien aux états unis le risque
c'est à travers les salaires c'est à
dire que aujourd'hui byden avec son
dernier plan notamment de 1900 milliards
de dollars qui a été déversé à partir de
mars et qui a profité aux ménages
américains parce que chaque américain a
pu recevoir un chèque de 1300 $ + est
bien déçu tu soutiens supplémentaires en
matière d'indemnisation du chômage
eh bien on voit que les américains sont
en train de peser le pour et le contre
et ce disque finalement retourner sur le
marché du travail
oui mais à quel prix mais bon il faut
quand même se dire que les aides vont se
tarir les aides de joe biden ça va être
finalement ça va s'éteindre et les
américains ils n'ont pas le système de
protection sociale que nous nous avons
en europe et en particulièrement et
particulièrement en france donc de fait
ils vont devoir retrouver un travail et
non pas tant de marge de négociation que
ça sur le salaire sur les salaires donc
moi je ne pense pas qu'il y aura deux
menaces sur l'inflation et comme l'a
expliqué très bien philippe et bien
c'est bien cette menace de l'inflation
qui pourrait en fait atteindre les
remettre en cause notre croissance à
part avec notamment une hausse des taux
d'intérêt donc moi mon mon analyse c'est
que et bien à moyen terme il n'y a pas à
craindre une surchauffe sur sur les prix
est ce qui est une bonne chose pour la
reprise
[Musique]